[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue pour cette nouvelle
semaine d'information locale sur tv 78
nous sommes le lundi 3 mai voici les
titres de ce journal levée de la règle
des 10 km fin de l'attestation de
déplacement réouverture des collèges et
lycées en 2011 le déconfinement est
enclenché il va se faire en plusieurs
étapes jusqu'à la fin juin et des lieux
fermés attendent les réouvertures avec
impatience reportage dans une maison
d'hôtes à magny les hameaux et dans une
salle de sport à guyancourt et invité
également béatrice piron député des
yvelines est le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines joue les
prolongations au vendredi le site
transformé en bacs cynodrome a
fonctionné jusqu'à minuit près de 500
personnes ont pu recevoir une injection
sur place une opération qui devrait se
renouveler
et puis la reconnaissance de la ville de
plaisir à anaïs dos santos est élève du
lycée jean vilar a sauvé son professeur
de l'étouffement grâce à des gestes de
premiers secours
elle a reçu une médaille pour cette
action héroïque politique également à
suivre dans ce journal avec la majorité
ensemble pour les yvelines qui vient de
dévoiler la liste de ses candidats pour
les élections départementales
ce lundi marque la première grande étape
du déconfinement à partir d'aujourd'hui
plus besoin d'attestation en journée
c'est aussi la fin de la règle des 10 km
pour les déplacements le calendrier va
s'étendre jusqu'à la fin juin avec une
réouverture progressive des lieux fermés
elle réactions dans ce sujet des
professionnels yvelinois et des
yvelinois également avec astrid berges
rc yaga tsongo bérengère bourgoin et
nina da silva lundi 3 mai ce jour est
celui de la première étape du
déconfinement c'est la fin de la limite
des 10 km et plus besoin d'attestation
en journée pour les professionnels du
tourisme cette date est importante
la seule interrogation les clients
reviendront-ils ça dépend de la volonté
de chacun et de ceux qui ont besoin de 2
sortir de leur appartement en fait qui
ont besoin d'avoir un peu de verdure
alors oui ils vont nous ils commencent à
nous appeler pour les week-end qui
arrive ici avant la crise les clients
étaient principalement des hommes
d'affaires maintenant compte davantage
de personnes en déplacement pour des
chantiers mais aussi des franciliens qui
ont besoin des autres grandes dates le
19 mai réouverture des commerces des
lieux culturels et des terrasses avec un
couvre-feu à 21h les avis illinois sur
ce calendrier sont mitigés si les gens
se protègent avec des masques et 6 des
toits bien démarré tout ça ça ne doit
pas poser de problème simplement c'est
la vaccination qu'il faut que absolument
qu'il se joue sur chaque site
je trouve que c'est un peu trop tôt je
trouve qu'il faudrait qu'on libère
certaines choses où il ya vraiment moins
de risques possibles pour voir la
situation commencera et d'après aller au
delà en nous avons attendu et nous avons
donné des efforts et aujourd'hui tout le
monde doit profiter de ça le couvre-feu
sera repoussé à 23 heures le 9 juin
cette date marquera aussi la réouverture
des salles de sport avec un respect des
jauges un soulagement pour les gérants
d'établissements sportif la première
impression qu on a listé le ouf enfin on
a pu enfin avoir une vision avoir une
date
donc ça c'était le jeu la chose qu'on
attendait le plus qu'on a été
malheureusement très kim est baladé de
date en date c'était décembre puis début
janvier plus fin janvier mais il fait
vriller pour après dire ben on verra
plus tard
donc là c'est vraiment un ouf de
soulagement la fin du processus de
déconfinement devrait avoir lieu le 30
juin avec la levée du couvre-feu des
ajustements pourraient avoir lieu en
fonction des situations sanitaires
locales seuls les discothèques resteront
fermés à béatrice pire on est avec nous
par visioconférence bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes la députée la république en marge
de la 3ème circonscription des yvelines
parle avec goût de ce calendrier dévoilé
dans la presse régionale
vendredi par emmanuel macron et un
calendrier en quatre dates qu'il faut
retenir ce lundi 3 mai le 19 mai avant
les dates aussi des 9 et 30 juin
ce lundi vous le voyez à s'afficher
levée de la limite des 10 km et de
l'attestation à otenir couvre-feu aussi
qui va progressivement passer de 19 à 21
heures 21 heures ce sera le 19 mai puis
23 heures le 9 mai
levée totale du couvre-feu à la fin juin
et aussi bien sûr qui est attendu avec
impatience et la réouverture progressive
des lieux fermés avec la prochaine étape
du 19 mai qui concerne les terrasses les
lieux culturels et les commerces
c'est un calendrier béatrice piron qui
pourraient être revus localement s'il ya
une dégradation de la situation a dit le
président de la république
malgré ce risque il était importante
tout de même de fixer le cap qu'on a vu
dans le sujet précédent il ya ces
sentiments assez mitigé finalement chez
les yvelinois il ya même plutôt de
l'impatience 1 chez les chez les
professionnels il fallait fixer ce cap
malgré le risque peut-être d'une
recrudescence de l'épidémie
oui alors aujourd'hui donc il ya sept ce
plafond ce seuil à quatre cents 400 cas
pour 100000 habitants si jamais on
revenait au dessus de ce seuil les dates
pourrait être repoussée mais aujourd'hui
on est largement en dessous les mines
aujourd'hui s'oriente à 307 1307 ça fait
sens et on est parti le week-end peuvent
avouer mon état 416 donc on a descendu
de 100 ans à peine dix jours je pense
que d'ici le 19 ans pas encore 13 en
deux ou trois cents bon je crois que le
risque est vraiment inexistant si les
gens continuent à respecter les gestes
barrière c'est le message que voulait
faire passer malgré la levée progressive
de ces mesures restrictives il faut
garder justement de la prudence oui
c'est ce qui nous permettra d'aller
jusqu'au mois de juin est de réussir à
tour et ouvrir et à reprendre une vie
est normale
à condition de faire même attention on
sait que les situations aussi des
variants brésilien et indien inquiète
est ce que finalement ce calendrier pour
être respecté ce qu'on ne va pas trop
vite
à votre avis je crois que s'est étalée
sur deux mois pleins donc faut rester
optimiste et sur tout ce qui est en
parallèle à cette progressivité de
déconfinement va aller en augmentant
c'est le nombre de vaccinés donc déjà
des confinement est très progressif mais
le nombre de vaccinés augmente donc on
est aujourd'hui à environ 15 millions de
vaccinés le 15 mai on sera un million
sera 30 millions fin juin
donc je tout cela va aller renforcer en
fin de compte la baisse du nombre de
contaminations de personnes avec une
stratégie qui a été adopté par le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs semaines
celle de la territorialité et aussi de
la progressivité là ça se fait étape par
étape ça c'est une stratégie qui fait du
sens ben oui ça avec a annoncé depuis
débats ont quoi il faut qu'on te barrer
ouvrir tout d'un coup parce qu'autrement
on verrait rêve remonter les taux
d'incidence donc il faut le faire un
processus très progressive et je crois
que c'est ce qu'a dit retenue alors ce
lundi c'est aussi le retour en classe
pour les élèves de collège et les élèves
de lycées après quatre semaines de
fermeture des établissements et une
demie jauge qui a été instauré pour les
élèves de lycées aussi pour les élèves
du collège dans les yvelines puisque les
yvelines font partie un des quinze
départements français les plus touchés
par l'épidémie
vous je précise également béatrice pian
vous êtes membre de la commission des
affaires culturelles et de l'éducation à
l'assemblée nationale est-ce que sur
votre territoire de la 3e
circonscription les échos que vous avez
eue aujourd'hui ce que cette rentrée
s'est bien déroulé celle aussi la
semaine dernière qui concernait les
élèves de primaire et de maternelle
oui les élèves de primaire sont déjà
rentrés et tout se passe bien
aujourd'hui c'est le collège donc avec
les 4e et 3e en admis georges donc une
partie des élèves qui sont à distance
je pense que tout ça s'est bien déroulé
et je crois que si on continue à garder
des gestes-barrières on devrait éviter
trop de fermeture de classe ça peut
arriver c'est ce qui est important
autant au niveau des enfants à des
familles mais aussi des enseignants donc
j'ai eu la semaine dernière par exemple
thür décolle donc subitement toute une
école qui a fermé parce que il n'y avait
pas eu de gestes barrière pendant le
temps des jeunes et des enseignants
mais je vois qu'il vaut mieux toujours
calmes ouvrir et globalement aujourd'hui
tous les collèges avec potentiellement
être un risque de une ou de fermeture
parce qu'aujourd'hui on était en tension
on a du mal à trouver des remplaçants
si l'enseignant ou si elle est lavée et
malade
donc on ferme la classe mais il vaut
mieux pas se fermer que toutes les
classes de cordes avec un protocole
renforcé en précisant que dès qu'un cas
positifs et décelés parmi les élèves ya
une fermeture qui est décrété et je
précise que d'après les derniers
chiffres de l'académie de versailles 39
classes ont été fermées la semaine
dernière dans les yvelines style reprise
primordial on sait qu'il ya le brevet le
baccalauréat qui approche
pour le moment ce grand oral est
toujours maintenue a annoncé le ministre
de l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer
même si des syndicats lycéens je le
précise appelé à des blocages
aujourd'hui il fallait une reprise
puisqu'il ya des échéances qui arrivent
qui vont arriver très vite
je pense qu'il faut aussi commencer à en
ravir avec ce virus ça fait maintenant
plus de noms là l'année dernière de
façon très exceptionnelle les épreuves
avaient été supprimés aujourd'hui le bac
elle réalisé préfinale se résume à deux
seules épreuves alors d'habitude maca
lauréats se fait avec une dizaine ou une
douzaine d'épreuves
donc je pense que deux épreuves sont
très raisonnables
une épreuve écrite et une épreuve orale
où l'élève et tous ceux dans la classe
avec un jury de deux enseignants parce
que cela permet de respecter les
distances et s'est passé de une bonne
façon c'est important de préparer les
élèves alors futures études et elle a à
la vie la vie d'adulte
oui et une dernière chose sur la reprise
dans les lycées avec le gouvernement qui
a prévu la diffusion de 60 millions
d'autos test pour le personnel soignant
et les lycéens avec un déploiement qui
se veut progressive un casque car ce
matin très peu d'établissements france
ils en étaient pourvus
les élèves se testeront directement à
leur lycée une fois par semaine dans une
salle qui doit être dédiée sous la
surveillance d'un professionnel de santé
ou d'un personnel de l'éducation
nationale est ce que c'est une campagne
qui est réalisable parce que ça demande
finalement beaucoup de logistique
syndicats d'enseignants ont remis en
cause aujourd'hui la faisabilité en
dénonçant dans un communiqué un cahier
des charges irréaliste est-ce que ce
cette campagne est réalisable
c'est évidemment difficile je comprends
leur leurs remorques c'est pas si simple
que ça mais je suis sûr que certains y
arriveront donc on va essayer de trouver
les meilleures méthodes et et après de
les généraliser pour tous les
établissements si certains y arrivent ou
pas les autres n'y arriverez pas je
crois qu'il faut être optimiste
les les élèves vont apprendre à
s'entraîner peut-être la première fois
chez eux et après ce sont des gestes qui
sauront faire facilement
c'est toujours la première la première
fois qui est difficile après ça ça va
rentrer dans des gestes usuelles merci
et béatrice piron d'avoir été avec nous
et je rappelle vous êtes la députée la
république en marge de la 3ème
circonscription des yvelines
si le déconfinement été enclenché le
couvre feu lui reste bien en vigueur à
19 heures samedi soir les forces de
l'ordre ont procédé à une centaine de
verbalisation pour non respect du
couvre-feu
lors de deux soirées clandestines l'une
dans un restaurant avenue de la gare à
coignières qui avait convié plus de 90
personnes le propriétaire des lieux a
reçu une amende pour ouverture d'un lieu
au public malgré la fermeture de
l'établissement
l'autre soir et s'est elle déroulée à
carrières-sur-seine en plein air un
groupe de jeunes de 22 jeunes a été
verbalisé une femme de 21 ans a été
également interpellés pour violences sur
une personne dépositaire de l'autorité
publique
une vaccination possible jusqu'à minuit
vendredi dernier le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines a joué les
prolongations le vaccinodromes a reçu
près de 500 patients pour une première
injection et ce en nocturne une décision
prise pour faciliter l'accès aux soins
pour les travailleurs le reportage de
mélanie poké près de 500 et viennois
vacciner la nocturne au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines a eu du succès
une ouverture jusqu'à minuit ce vendredi
30 avril pour recevoir les patients en
activité j'ai très très bien
très bien parce que moins ça permet de
venir en dehors des horaires du boulot
pour les personnes qui travaillent qui
travaillent tard jusqu'à 18 19 heures
c'est une très bonne idée effectivement
23 ça permet de faire ce en dehors des
heures de bureau
c'est une bonne opportunité pour ceux
qui travaillent en trop qui
voilà ça ouvre plus de créneaux quoi
pouvoir profiter l'agglomération note
que 50% des patients viennent de
l'extérieur de saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette première soirée ce sont des
doses pfizer qui ont été administrés 500
primovaccination les gens qui
travaillent et bien ils ont ils
travaillent la journée et donc il faut
qu'il y ait une le soir donc voilà voilà
la raison et deuxièmement ça nous fait
nous ne nous préparer puisque bien
entendu on se sent bien que il ya plus
de gens de 50 ans que jones 60 donc mais
sûr ça va en quantité il faut se
préparer à augmenter bien sûr le nom de
l'acsi nation après cette première
soirée test le vélodrome sera en
nocturne tous les vendredis soirs depuis
le 1er mai la vaccination est ouverte
aux français de plus de 18 ans souffrant
d'une ou de plusieurs co morbidités le
vaccinodromes qui se fixe comme objectif
d'atteindre les 100 mille vaccination
d'ici dimanche prochain
et en parallèle de cette campagne de
vaccination les indicateurs du coc vie
19 dans les yvelines sont tous en baisse
depuis une semaine les chiffres restent
tout de même élevé le taux d'incidence
est à dire le nombre de nouveaux
contaminée pour 100000 habitants a
reculé de 91 points ils s'établissaient
le 29 avril à 308 dans le département et
diminution également du taux de tests
positifs qui reste au-dessus des 10% à
la situation quoique toujours tendu
s'améliore légèrement dans les hôpitaux
592 personnes étaient hospitalisées hier
dimanche sur le territoire 109 toujours
en réanimation et depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire 1704 patients sont
décédés du comique 19 dans les hôpitaux
yvelinois
un mot de politique locale avec les
élections départementales qui approche
les scrutins sont au programme le
scrutin est au programme le 20 et 27
juin prochains et la liste des candidats
d'ensemble pour les yvelines est connu
ce samedi 1er mai depuis mantes la jolie
le président sortant du département
pierre bédier a présenté les 21 binôme
investi par la majorité départementale
les détails dans ce reportage de nicolas
landry une investiture par
visioconférence crise sanitaire oblige
la majorité départementale ensemble pour
les yvelines a dévoilé les 21 binôme en
lice pour les élections du 20 et 27 juin
prochains une présentation en présence
d'un soutien d'envergure le travail qui
est fait par le conseil départemental
pour le territoire des yvelines pour les
yvelinoises des yvelinois pour les
communes des yvelines et travail de
qualité que ce soit dans le domaine
social dans le domaine de l'aménagement
des communes dans le domaine de la
voirie dans le domaine des collèges dans
ce mandat débuté en 2015 les binômes de
l'union de la droite de l'ump est classé
divers droite avaient obtenu
respectivement 22 16 et 4 sièges
une assemblée sans opposition avec un
rassemblement de la droite et du centre
pour le prochain scrutin
l'union sera plus large ensemble pour
les yvelines c'est le rassemblement
c'est ce que j'appelle le rassemblant du
juste milieu c'est-à-dire des gens
modérés de centre-droit de centre-gauche
qui se retrouvent là parce qu'ils sont
d'accord sur les objectifs et les
méthodes pour atteindre ces objectifs
les questions de la vie quotidienne que
sont les collèges les aides aux communes
l'aide sociale à l'enfance les questions
de son terme sur les 42 candidats une
majorité d'élus sortants 16 nouveaux
visages tout de même s'engage sous la
bannière ensemble pour les yvelines
parmi les nouveaux des représentants du
modem des yvelines officiellement engagé
dans la majorité départementale
à l'image de richard ii le pierre ou
encore des maires élus l'année dernière
il faisait partie des quelques maires
qui incarne clairement cette cet
élargissement la majorité et qu'ensuite
on proposition qui nous a été faite il
ya maintenant presque un an sur lequel
on a le temps de réfléchir et donc le
parti que je représente le modem
souhaité donner une suite favorable
nous avons aujourd'hui une situation
kuhn traversant qui est assez difficiles
et pour laquelle je pense sera pas trop
dit travailler à la fois avec les
compétences de la ville de
l'intercommunalité et du département
avec le département je sais que demain
nous pourrons aussi avoir ce ce prisme
là d'intervention parmi les autres
candidats on retrouve karl olive
catherine arnould alexandra rose et thé
ou encore olivier lebrun qui s'engagent
pour tenter de repartir pour un nouveau
mandat dans l'actualité également ce
rassemblement à son champ hier dimanche
près de 150 personnes se sont réunies en
mémoire de justin le sapeur pompier de
19 ans s'est tué dans un accident de
moto vendredi il se rendait à la caserne
de rambouillet pour prendre son service
et participent à l'encadrement de
l'hommage national à la fonctionnaire de
police
stéphanie montfermeil tué par un
terroriste après la cérémonie qui s'est
tenue vendredi à rambouillet le premier
ministre jean castex accompagné par
d'autres ministres et élus se sont
rendus à la caserne où officiait le
jeune pompier les honneurs de la commune
de plaisir à anaïs dos santos cet élève
de terminale au lycée jean vilar a reçu
vendredi la médaille de la ville
une distinction pour saluer son geste
héroïque celui de sauver son professeur
de l'étouffement lé détail de celles
yaga tsongo et de joe sakal médaillés
pour avoir sauvé la vie de son
professeur anaïs dos santos élève en
terminale au lycée jean vilar à plaisir
a reçu vendredi 30 avril jour de son
anniversaire
la médaille de la ville pour son geste
héroïque la semaine dernière sept jeunes
filles à pratiquer la manoeuvre de
heimlich sur son professeur qui était en
train de s'étouffer avec un petit gâteau
pendant une pause interclasses d'un
moment j'ai senti une pression sur
l'estomac et en fait c'était risqué à
moi qui m'a compris mais l'estomac et du
coup à gérer curgy telle ou le gâteau
par terre et pop j'ai retrouvé le reste
ira soit tu y ait un geste tout simple
que elle m'a sauvé la vie que c'est ça
qui est incroyable et elle est la
présence d'esprit de sang-froid et la
prend et screen intervenir c'est
vraiment assez extraordinaire ce gestes
de premiers secours à nice dos santos
l'a appris au collège en soit le p100 là
ça se résume pas non plus qu à la
manoeuvre de heimlich quoi ça nous
apprend aussi à voir
enfin apprendre les appeler les pompiers
enfin leur donner les bonnes infos tout
ça donc c'est vrai que j'ai une seule
bnf quoi c'est plein d'autres choses
vont rester
c'est bien de le savoir en fait présente
lors de la cérémonie la mère de plaisir
à saluer le courage de la jeune fille
quand il ya des jeunes je veux dire qui
qui qui seraient pas venus même
d'ailleurs nous le dire parce que moi
j'avoue que je n'ai appris presque plus
par la presse lorsqu'il ya une modestie
derrière eh bien il faut valoriser sa et
montrer qu'on a une très belle jeunesse
il faut il faut vraiment le faire
oui c'est important le professeur benoît
meurice encore ému et choqué de cet
événement cherche désormais à passer le
certificat de prévention et secours
civiques
à l'image d'un ace avant de vous laisser
la date est parmi les plus importantes
de l'année pour les fleuristes le 1er
mai fête du travail
l'occasion également d'offrir du muguet
et la petite fleur en forme de
clochettes blanches a été plébiscité ce
week-end avec la règle et des 10 km la
vente ambulante était plus compliqué
cette année les yvelinois se sont donc
plus largement tournés vers leur
fleuriste qui ont été très vite à court
de stock c'est le cas dans cette
enseigne de montigny le bretonneux
ouverte depuis octobre dernier dès le
vendredi et samedi matin une centaine de
clients s'est rendu dans la boutique
résultat plus de muguet le samedi
après-midi la gérante a été pour le
moins surprise par cette affluence
ecoutez-la au micro dé l'honneur si
nokia ouvert dès 8 heures et dès 8
heures à midi c'était non stop
alors c'est notre premier 1er mai ici
donc on a quand même prévu pas mal de
quantité mais on s'était dit qu'on
n'était pas les seuls à en vendre
donc on a prévu quand même beaucoup de
brun et on avait beaucoup de peau aussi
à replanter et malgré ça on a la preuve
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité très belle soirée avec tv
[Musique]